thank you
[Applause]
my car
you need to back off and waste this
outfit Eugene get out of here
you're making a mistake you made a
mistake when you messed with my client
because now I'm gonna whoop your ass
my ass remains unwoofed yeah
let's fix that
um well I've already wasted half a
Sunday on this Expedition so I'm gonna
get moving
oh my God
[Applause]
oh what the hell is going on it's just
two men working through the resentments
in a safe environment Jen sorry that's
my fault you know what apologize to my
Prius Prime with money I absolutely
apologize to your Prius if that'll make
you feel better
brother blocky has actually taught me a
lot about taking responsibility for my
anger man bull it was a weird lab
experiment don't ask and I am
and before you make assumptions no I am
not a matador that would make the two of
us fighting pretty cliche no he's
working through some identity issues I
am not the one with the issues all right
I know exactly who I am
I am a swashbuckler you keep saying that
like it's an actual occupation